you must have strong feelings about
current events and politics
generally given your experience yet you
remain silent on this
issue why to appeal to a larger audience
or the soldier's mentality of not
criticizing the commander-in-chief
is that why do i have strong feelings
on current events and politics
uh sure i do but
they're more broad so i have very strong
broad feelings
on current events and politics i am a
patriotic person i believe
very strongly in individual freedoms of
human beings i believe in having a very
strong military i believe in having a
small government
so i have strong feelings about those
things however
i don't have strong feelings about the
nonsense and micro dramas that are on
the 24-hour news cycle
that are just cons and social media just
constant
things and we talked about this last
podcast things that don't matter
so much of the current events
don't really matter in the big picture
to me or even to the
country and you know i was
uh on ben shapiro show and
you know he was i basically said look
look like overall americans have sort of
the same
goals and he said i don't know if i
believe that
and i said well i
work with all kinds of companies with
people all over the country
and the people that a guy like ben
shapiro
hears from he's just he's just bombarded
by the extremes on both sides 24 hours a
day
i don't want to be in that position of
getting bombarded by these extremes 24
hours a day
i said ben you're right there are some
people in the country that believe
the far left or the far right i said
most people are concerned about
their life and doing a good job and you
know building their business
or you know paying down their mortgage
that's what they're concerned about and
so they're not like freaking out about
the little
every little micro drama that gets
unleashed into
the press and social media every single
day
and so so why do i not join into that
because i don't
want to join into that and also i don't
want to make a podcast
i don't want to spend all my time making
a podcast that's that's
out of date the day it comes out like i
don't i don't want to invest my time in
that
i don't want to and guess what there's
there's literally
giant multi-billion dollar news media
outlets and guess what they do that's
what they do all day
that's what they do all day they make a
story about this thing and that thing
and this thing
i can't react fast enough it's just dumb
so
if we were to be talking about current
events then by the time the podcast
comes out the
current event has been over some people
are listening to this podcast and it's
it's
it's 2022 right now right now
some someone is listening to this
podcast right now and it's 2022.
no there's there's no topic of current
events that we could talk about
or barely any that actually impact
what's happening four years from now
people i meet people every day now
i meet people that are that say hey oh
man i've been listening to podcasts i'm
on
28. um that's that's two years ago
right that's two years ago what was the
what was the current events two years
ago they were
it's totally different than they are now
yeah so
so there's that so that's why little
current events thing as far as appealing
to a larger audience that part of the
question
well if my goal was to appeal to a large
larger audience then i think i actually
would talk about the trendy stories of
the day
and put out little little clips of the
sound bites of all this stuff and
instead of instead of doing what i do
now which is to read a hundred year old
out of print books like that's a great
way to build an audience
or let's talk about the rwandan genocide
or let's talk about the holocaust so
let's talk about the rape and dan king
or let's talk about the meli massacre
that ought to build a great audience so
so the idea that oh i'm trying to build
a larger audience it's like no
actually people that want to listen to
this want to listen to it i'm not trying
to
i'm not trying to build an audience by
manipulating what what i'm thinking
about no i'm actually
i'm i'm talking about and i'm diving
into
what i find important and what i
think i can learn from and i get more
out of this podcast than
anybody i mean i know a lot of people
say oh i've got a lot from your podcast
i get more out of it than anybody
because i get to dive deep into this
stuff and
really look at it so
no it's not the trying to appeal to a
larger audience in fact if i want a lot
of
larger audience i'd do exactly what
you're talking about
as far as the soldier's mentality of not
criticizing the commander-in-chief
i actually don't agree i don't agree
that that's a soldier's mentality and i
don't believe that it should be a
soldier's mentality
the soldier should question their
leadership
and now should they do it tactfully
absolutely because i don't want to be
surrounded by yes man that's that's
wrong
also if you what am i trying
this is just a general leadership
principle what have i said a thousand
times on this podcast i'm trying to
build a relationship with the person
above me in the chain of command
so when i was a in the military if i
wanted to have
influence over my boss over my
commander-in-chief would i outwardly
criticize them and make
make them think oh this guy just doesn't
like me i'm going to take my first
chance to get rid of him or
not promote him no i'm actually going to
play the game
and i'm going to look and say okay boss
hey i see what you're doing here i want
to support what you're doing but does
this make sense can we do it a different
way
so i'm trying to build a relationship
with my boss up the chain of command i'm
not trying to ostracize him
by by making them look bad or by openly
criticizing
my boss in in uh you know in the open
because what have i done is my boss
going to listen to me no actually my
boss is going to listen to me at all
so i don't want to be surrounded by yes
men
but at the same time if someone's making
a bad decision if someone's doing
something that's immoral or illegal i'll
call them out on it all day long
now the other thing that happens here is
this is a new world
and it's a and this is a binary world
of sound bytes that's what we've done
we've created this bina
binary world of sound bites
when most answers that you want to give
as a human being
aren't one sentence or two sentence on
the far left or far right
or far light or far dark like there's
going to be
you have to explain things a little bit
more and but when you take these binary
sound bites
everyone's immediately thrown into an
extreme category
on the far left or the far right as and
as soon and here's the bad part here's
the really bad part
as soon as you get thrown into one of
those camps
then ha the other camp stops listening
to you completely
you know they stop listening to you
anything you say
so you could you could
make a great point but if you're on the
other side
doesn't matter no one's listening they
don't want to hear it because you're on
the other side you're the enemy it's a
binary world
you're either with me or against me and
there's no in-between so that's kind of
what we've created
and what i would rather do is have
people actually listen to what i say
broadly and make their own choices
rather than me trying to force an
opinion down their throat this is the
way it is this is the way it should be
and by the way just like leadership you
can't force people you can't force an
opinion down someone's throat it doesn't
work
you can't sure it'll work for 30 seconds
it'll work for five minutes it'll work
for five days in a leadership session
yeah you better do what i say
my way is right eventually you that kind
of leadership does not work
and it's the same thing with trying to
force an opinion down someone's front
throat
if you listen to what i'm saying you can
form your own opinion and i would rather
have you do that because that's going to
be stronger than
some opinion that i tried to force down
your throat which doesn't work by the
way
so i would rather people listen to me
and not just sound bikes and see where
i'm coming from holistically
and see where they can agree and
disagree and see what feedback they give
me because by the way i could be wrong
about something which i have no problem
with
but i would rather do that i would
rather have that approach
then join the pack whichever pack that
is join the pack
on the street and bark loudly like the
rest of the dogs
i have no interest in doing that so
there you go
agree dang bro
and it's funny man you're you're like
one of the few
people who i mean i you know like that
whole thing i mean to sum that up i mean
i've heard that before where someone
would be like hey i'm you know i'm like
this one but it's so very it's so few
people
that actually do that the way the way
you do even in real life like
in real life like you you don't even
when political stuff will come up
it's real obvious that you didn't jump
into any net specific group
yeah so well this this really ties back
to last week's podcast
of getting involved in things that don't
matter
and there is there's just so much out
there that doesn't matter
now where you have to be careful is that
that there's so many things that don't
matter but what i am not saying
that little things don't matter you see
what i'm saying there's a huge disparity
between those two things
there's a lot of things that don't
matter what i am not saying is that
little things
don't matter because there are little
things that do
matter and the classic example that we
brought up over and over and over again
on this podcast it's like oh
the russian soldier's not shaving in
chechnya and how that led to their
eventually okay not gonna shave now
we're not gonna clean our weapons now
now we're not gonna stay awake on a
watch now we're not gonna keep the
missions we're being told to do
now we're getting beat there are little
things that matter
but if i'm barking all day long about
things that don't matter
then we have a problem we have a problem
now i'll tell you something else there's
been some issues that have come up
lately
there was one issue that i was going to
address on the podcast but
and i still might address it because
it's a small problem that i see as being
a more
significant problem and
if it continues down the road but but
luckily at this point
there's there's a whole pack of dogs
barking about it
it wasn't like it wasn't like i noticed
this problem and no one else saw it it
was like i noticed this problem
so did millions of other people and they
all those dogs start barking okay so now
what am i gonna do
bark with them yeah it's like okay now
if there comes a time where all of a
sudden i realize there's one of these
small things that matter or big things
that matter
that i don't see getting the traction
that it needs
well then i will absolutely say hey this
is what i think
about this situation generally
there's so many people barking and
they're barking about the same thing
they're barking about a lot of things
that don't matter they're barking about
some things that matter
and right now unless i mean what do i
say all the time the less
the less you speak the more people
listen yeah so if i want to give my
my opinion on the daily news every hour
on the hour
no one's listening to anything i've got
to say and then it's a waste
it's a waste it's a waste of my time
because there's more important there are
more important things
when we can when we can dive into human
nature through the lens
of war through the lens of leadership
through the war of atracity we can learn
and teach people about the past so we
can prevent it from happening in the
future
that to me is infinitely more impactful
than barking about
some current event that's happening
that's going to be gone
in a week it's it's amazing how f
how fast stuff comes up on the radar
it's all over the headlines and in a
week it's gone
in a week it's gone yeah so i'm just not
gonna play that game
i have i i don't there's no point in
doing it
that's a really good way to put it it's
like these current events
most of the time seem to be shaped in a
way to just
for dogs to bark about you know like
that's what it is like here
and then then they bark and the next
thing you know yeah okay bark about this
now
the the sound bite thing is really
interesting too
everything is a sound bite and it either
puts you in one camp or the other camp
and the fact of the matter is you can't
put me in a camp
you can't yeah because i got beliefs
that you don't understand
on one side on the other side yeah you
know and so
you can't talk to me about that kind of
thing you can't not that you can't talk
you can't put me in a camp but the
instinct of the
world right now is take that person and
put them in a camp
i'm not going in the camp that's what's
happening
if you want to figure out what i'm
thinking listen what i'm saying about
listen to what i'm saying
in hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
hours where i talk about
human nature right if you want to figure
that out
and then you want to ask me a pointed
question about something cool ask it
bring it if it's something that's gonna
if it's if it's a bark
if you want me to bark about something
i'm probably not gonna bark about it
so what throwing you in a camp all you'd
have is a whole lot of unhappy campers
no you throw me in a camp if you put me
in one camp
the other camp doesn't listen anymore
yeah
and that and that means their minds are
closed so they're not gonna
and is the fact the matter is there's
there's good people in in both camps
yeah and
and both people can be
can be can change and can accept new
ideas
if their mind is open if their mind
isn't open they're just stay in their
camp
and everyone else i mean when you watch
the extremes of either camp right now
it's it's like it's like really it's
it's bizarro world yeah it's kind of odd
yeah so you you just
sit there and say okay what why am i
going to play that game
yeah let's just become better people
that understand people better and will
make better i'll
make the place make the world better
can't disagree
okay yeah the whole unhappy campers
those mean more making a joke i dig it
um
yeah i know it was a good attempt at
humor uh well actually no it wasn't
it was a failure but that's cool uh what
was the
the other point you made uh sometimes
it's better to just
just try you know and and oh they see
whatever thing
yeah yeah yeah see what up now i know
yeah now you know don't try that again
yeah
no more jokes from echo learn from my
my mistakes anyway